antes del comienzo de la guerra dura
trabajaba en el negocio de la moda ahora
utiliza sus antiguos conocimientos para
recaudar fondos para las mujeres del
ejército pero su uniforme no es sólo
para mostrar es lo que lleva cada día en
el frente donde vive en las mismas
condiciones que los hombres 2000 con
will johnson jess y chile y el hueco por
capas hay que saber hacer de todo
conducir camiones militares y cavar
trincheras es el ejército no se hacen
excepciones con nosotras
hay que estar preparada para todo
bolívar 29
pero el ejército ucraniano no estaba
preparado para una incorporación tan
grande de mujeres carece de equipamiento
diseñado para las mujeres soldados sur
espera que esta sesión de fotos con
zemliaski ayude a cambiar eso una parte
de los beneficios de la venta de joyas
se destinará a la compra de equipamiento
de cajones parte hemos encontrado
patrocinadores que nos están apoyando
con ayuda humanitaria algunos están
comprando uniformes otros placas para
chalecos antibalas cuestan mucho dinero
y los cascos tienen que ser más ligeros
y pequeños no son fáciles de encontrar
además de productos de higiene y ropa
interior femenina semillas que ya ha
suministrado 300 chalecos antibala para
mujeres que luchan en el frente
de
estas placas pesan menos de 3 kilos pero
dan una protección similar a las que
proporciona el ejército que pesan 5
kilos así que la protección es igual de
buena y son el doble de ligeras
dt ya cumple de armea
pero se mira aquí sabe que tiene que
intensificar sus esfuerzos con la
llegada del invierno se calcula que
50.000 mujeres van a necesitar uniformes
especialmente diseñados para el frío